a real-time present system allows users
to know whether or not their fellow
users are online offline or away in some
other idle status in this episode we're
going to use slack as our inspiration to
build a system that will show the status
of users throughout the app we're
building a fully fledged system that
will be able to detect whether or not a
users engaging with an app based on a
timer and also whether or not a user has
closed the app and update the status on
each of these events at this point I'm
assuming you have a basic authentication
system in place with angularfire - if
not I've added a link in the description
that discusses that topic more
extensively the first thing we want to
do is see if the user has an active
connection to the firebase real time
database
firebase keeps track of this information
in a secret location called info /
connected which we can subscribe to just
like anything else in the database this
tells us whether the current client has
a connection to the database so let's go
into our off service and put this to use
first we'll import the angularfire
database as well as angularfire auth and
the main firebase SDK then we'll set a
variable for the current user is user ID
and inside the constructor will
subscribe to the angular fire off state
which is just the currently logged in
user and if we have a user we're going
to set their user ID on the service and
also subscribe to that connection data
that I just described earlier when we
actually determine the current user
status we'll save it as the status
property under their user ID and the
real time database we're going to update
the status frequently so we'll create a
helper function that we can just pass
the status as an argument and that will
update the database so any time we
detect a status change we can call this
helper and the database gets updated
from there we can create another
function that will subscribe to the info
/ connected data which will just be a
boolean true or false if it's true we'll
set the user status to online and it's
false will set it to offline then we
call our helper function and subscribe
and we're all set if we go to the app we
can see that when we log in we have an
active connection to firebase so we
display the online status this works
okay when a user logs in but if they
close the window it's not going to
update the status to
wine thankfully a firebase has an on
disconnect callback that we can use to
listen for when the user disconnects
from the database to use this function
we need to interact with the firebase
SDK directly let's add another function
to our constructor this time called
update on disconnect it works by making
a reference to the user status in the
database and then calls the on
disconnect function and then updates the
status to offline so this function will
only run when the database connection is
disconnected in the app we have a logged
in user on the left and a non logged in
user on the right when the logged in
user closes the browser window it ends
the database connection and their status
is updated to offline so what if the
user has the app open but they're not
actively using it for that we want to
set a third status called away we can
manage that state by listening for Mouse
events in the browser and then resetting
a timer each time a new Mouse event
occurs if that timer expires then we can
set the status to away so we'll set up a
couple of subscriptions one for the
mouse event and one for the timer itself
then we'll create another function
called update on idle inside this
function we create an observable that's
listening to Mouse events in the Dom
Mouse events happen frequently so we
want to throttle them to happen only
every two seconds if you imagine each
circle representing a mouse of that
they'll be grouped into chunks and only
the first one that occurred in that
two-second period will be emitted when
we get them out event we can go ahead
and update the status to online because
we know the users engaged and we also
want to reset the timer which is
counting down to set the user to away
status the timer itself is a
subscription so if there's one existing
in the app we want to unsubscribe from
it then we create a new timer by calling
observable timer this time we're setting
it to five thousand milliseconds in real
life you probably want to set it a lot
longer than that then when that timer
runs out it'll set the status to away
and on a final note you probably want to
end these subscriptions when you no
longer need them for example if the user
signs out we'll go ahead and unsubscribe
from the mouse events as well as the
timer if we go into the app and just let
the mouse sit idle we can see after five
seconds the status gets updated - away
if we go back into the app immediately
updates back to online if I click logout
then it will update to offline now let's
go ahead and build the actual component
that the user sees on the front end so
here I have a list of users that I
pulled from the database and I'm going
to pass the user status to a child
component called user status we do this
by using the input decorator from
angular inside the user status component
typescript we just import input and then
declare a variable called status with
that decorator this situation is a
perfect time to use the ng switch
directive which works just like a switch
operator in JavaScript or any other
programming language we pass the user
status to ng switch and then we can use
an ng switch case to display different
templates depending on what the user
status is so if the users online we give
it a green success CSS class if they're
offline we give it a red CSS class and
so on this makes it easy to add your own
custom icons or whatever kind of
presentation you want to do here you can
also add an NG switch default which will
ensure that something displays if none
of the statuses match what you have in
the switch cases that's it for building
a user present system with angular 4 and
firebase if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and if you want
access to exclusive content and one on
one project consult team consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase com you'll get a free copy of
my book as well as access to our pro
members channel on flax thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you soon
[Music]